I think Americans need to understand
that like LMS are are great and they're
they're they're going to be uh
revolutionary mini categories typically
categories that were part search and
Discovery most of the Innovation around
llms are basically the ux experience the
secondary Innovation are things related
to creative power so Graphics photos
images but it doesn't mean that like
that's going to replace artists like you
know a Picasso is still a Picasso people
are getting way ahead of themselves in
terms of thinking that this is actually
going to accurately replic
the creative power of
humanity all right guys bang bang I've
got a great treat for you today Aaron is
here uh Aaron let's just jump right into
it you've been in Silicon Valley for uh
quite a while and you've held a number
of views that maybe weren't so popular
now have become much more popular I
think it maybe the first place to just
start is like how do you continue to
think critically and independently when
everybody around you was yelling and
screaming the exact opposite of the
views that you held
uh I mean yeah I've been cancell three
times in my life so far uh so first time
was because I hosted a liberty
hackathon and uh and C ranul also came I
think like a day or two before and San
Francisco Chronicle called me a racist
uh by the way my family fled uh
communism from China and my co-founder
is black so they didn't really like to
look us up then and then I got canceled
again uh for voting for Trump uh so I
was the only conservative executive my
tech company uh I also went to the rep I
went to three Republican debates so I
became the soft target there and then I
canceled again for my views on co uh
like big time Cancel like
major so I it's just you know my my dad
uh who is you know the most kind of
Chinese American person you could ever
think of uh once told me that uh you
know people aren't going to like you for
uh for how you look or or what you think
and B just said f them right so he told
me that when I was like eight and that
has been like kind of uh instilled in me
for since then um but yeah I I think I
was one of the first quote unquote unclo
the Republicans in silon Valley back in
2013 um and uh and so yeah I've been
since then it's just been kind of second
nature to me like the fact that like in
my mind as probably as your mind too
it's kind of bizarre to me that you
would like disassociate with someone
because they like generally think of
something within quite mainstream and
let's say mainstream's above like 10% of
the population uh and that's just really
foreign to me and I don't do that to
those people but they do it to me and
that's just never been completely clear
to me but they just sort of do it and uh
in Sil Valley especially when when I
went there you know it was like hard
idea hard on ideas easy on people right
things like that and and then it kind of
has molded definitely underneath Obama
the it molded into like a calentate IG
Galaxy of like Pur puritanical wokeism
right and then it just sort of
accelerated as like TR Trump broke broke
people's brains right
um but I kind of stayed where I was
which was kind of like the
same uh kind of like libertarian asque
uh kind of anti neoliberalism uh
orientation uh but yeah yeah I think Sil
Mell has gone through this like breaking
point though because uh it was easy to
punch at Trump but then postco post like
the Trump Administration uh I think it
has created a massive fissure in Sil Val
which I think is good because you see
aogs and the Hamas thing they Ren new
War it's also another one like you you
see a break in silen valley right where
you see very I would say rational a
group of rational people who don't agree
on like if you ask all about abortion it
kind of varies right but they kind of
are on the zone of like we believe in
like freedom freedom of expression
rational argument and you got the other
side that basically takes the panical
wokeism side that it doesn't matter what
you say to them they're right they're
narcissists they're going to win right
uh and and that's kind of like where uh
the actual War has actually been but
it's kind of been mismatched between red
and blue when in reality like that's
always been the Divide uh in in in Tech
so you now are taking what I'll consider
a mental framework or a worldview that
uh was unpopular now becoming more
popular uh and you are quotequote
productizing it in terms of a company
today before we get to what you guys are
building with Hydra I want to just talk
about the Computing Wars Advanced
computer chips Etc what do kind of that
industry look like today and where do
you see problems that potentially could
be coming up that you want to go ahead
get ahead of and start addressing
now uh well I think that like
for what what Americans don't realize is
that it there's there's great
biographies written by about ma that I
think if most Americans read they would
be very shocked at like how uh seric or
should say suspicious and and the way in
which working with China is not like
working with any other good faith actor
in the West that like what they say what
they do is very very different and
they're very crafty and they're shrewd I
as an example like uh most of the
advanced Weaponry that like China has
stolen uh they didn't invent it they
stole it uh were basically different
ways of wedging the US and Russia
against each other and they create these
like fake uh media things right the the
one of the greatest example is when
Eisenhower uh basically threatened to
use the nuke over Taiwan that was a
whole setup
by Mao to convince uh the United States
to issue that threat and what Mao did
after that was go to the Soviet Union
and because Stalin thought Mt was crazy
like he's like this guy's freaking crazy
it literally coming from a mass murderer
right so that tells you how crazy was
like you know Stalin literally had a
list of people he would just go through
every night in terms who would get
executed right so and and he went to
Stalin he goes hey man like you don't
want to send Russian blood to defend
China give me nukes and he goes no
you're crazy and they came back again he
goes okay I'll send you Russian
scientist right that's how they got
nukes that's how they got Subs that's
how they got Jets right that's how they
got any sort of aircraft designs right
and the same thing they appli to the the
economy like if you look at most of the
uh the the highspeed trains there they
look a lot like German designs right
because they had German Engineers there
right so so this this is a a it's a very
different type of warfare that I think
Americans are sort of used to like a
Russian style of like let's just send
tanks in right they imagine that like
that's What conflict looks like versus
like conflict it comes to China is is
asymmetric and and very shrewd uh and so
when the co stuff came out that was the
lens of what I was looking at this stuff
because I mean I I knew Loosely about
Corona viruses because I started
researching it back like when the first
report started coming out and I was like
okay like this is not Stars 2.0 like
this is a bit exaggerated and they
started sending those videos of like
people falling in streets and I was like
no Corona virus does that like like that
that's like not a thing right and even
SARS didn't do that right and and and
then the the the storm just kept brewing
and Brewing right and and it was like
this this uh this Echo chamber effect
that created so much Social pressure on
the west to respond at like you know
basically the the the safety bias right
that like well we could be wrong so but
it doesn't matter we're going to bias
ver for safety versus what I saw was
like a propaganda campaign right that
that that that and I think that they did
not know was going to be that successful
because I think at First China it was
real like you know like starscope 2 is
real um but it manifested itself into
something they couldn't even control
anymore because it just took off so
successfully that you notice actually
once it started taking off successfully
in response to the it Italian outbreak
an outbreak is like a is a loose word
because it was already been there for
like four or five months uh all of a
sudden the news are trying to stops like
the data stops the reporting stops right
and this is after the the post Wuhan uh
you know the building the hospitals and
all this like hysteria that China was
pushing out into the world uh because at
that moment they knew oh wait we were
actually killing people like China was
killing people with its hysterical
response with how it was building and
promoting hospitals how it was like
treating patients that it was creating
hysteria right was actually causing
people to panic and then seeking
treatment they didn't need which is
having all these sort of secondary
effects right and then so the data stops
and they just sort of let it ride right
okay because that's actually how it's
try of works so when it comes to like
Computing right which is obviously
relates to gpus Nidia we to understand
that like they're not just seeking do AI
because it's cool and it like helps you
write a like an paper right they're
seeking AI for alternative ends mostly
to control their own population but but
secondarily to build sort of aerial like
AI to like try to take down the stock
exchange or electricity or state
governments or things like that uh and
trying to mostly create like fishing
schemes like how of like make that
better um uh but mostly they're trying
to do it to control eternally internally
their population uh which they don't
have great control over um and uh and so
but they are going to externalize it uh
so our country I don't think actually uh
you know one of the great things that of
the Trump Administration um that is an
objective like both parties would agree
is that he changed our view on China
like if you go back look at 2015 debates
nobody in the on that side maybe maybe
Rubio would be the only other one we're
saying China's a risk it's the biggest
risk to us who cares about Russia
they're basically just want to be a
drunk mobster in the world they have no
interest in replacing us as the king
they just want to Annoy Us they're like
the second cousin lives down the street
that's in kind of a like a kind of
crappy house right and but he has a
really nice car and really nice to watch
us right that's Russia he has no
interest in running the neighborhood or
running the HOA no interest right he
just kind of wants to bother people and
get paid off with like nice things so
China though is like you know is wants
to run the HOA right they want to run
the neighborhood right and Trump saw
that and like whether he did or advisor
I don't really care but he changed the
orientation of our country to see that
as the highest risk and that's actually
bipartisan issue now so the B
Administration uh issuing these Rags
which are very very restrictive rag now
on gpus uh they see that and and they're
basically getting ahead of the game
which I think is U like commendable um
with what but there's another side if
you look at the other regs they released
where they basically treat AI as if it's
like Skynet and that it's like int
actual intelligence versus just
basically a different way of doing
statistical modeling for machine
learning and uh and they're treating as
if it is like a risk to its own people
versus a risk of like an adversary using
our uh chips like basic say imp planting
stuff in the chip making to spy on us
which is kind of the biggest risk uh and
then secondarily down the risk would be
like them actually creating additional
like uh artificial llms that can do
fishing better is like way way down the
list uh even farther down the list is
actually creating an adversarial agent
to like let's say attack Stock Exchange
right like that's
possible but like almost almost like the
required computing power to do that
would be like a red red hot you know dot
on the map you just launch a missile at
that data center and blow it up or
something so like like the the the
amount of commuity power you need to to
do that would be insane um so the uh so
like I think that that that some of the
recent Rags though that the the EOS and
stuff like that coming out with the B
Administration views AI as if it was
written by someone who saw Terminator
too many times with Matrix uh and it's
kind of embarrassing and they they also
started adding if you read the RS like
it needs to include diversity inclusion
it needs to like who makes the models
and it has like weights against like
biasing against like white angelism
things like that which I don't even
understand how you would even measure
that like how do you measure like like
angelism in a model like like like if it
doesn't even make any sense right so so
even chath who's like obviously the
resident Democrat on on on I guess you
can ask Jason too but he's like this is
crazy this is just just stupid it's
literally like a Yale grad who's 27 who
read a book about AI just threw every
other prior you know into the EO and
then and then just spit it out there
right uh so I don't think it really goes
anywhere but because it's so crazy and
and even Amazon and Microsoft are like
who cares uh so like if they're not
going to report who's using their models
then then then then nobody is right
so now when you start to look at uh the
AI um maybe the the regulatory uh
scrutiny that it's receiving
it seems like that is very us focused
this happening in other areas as well
like are other geographies or other
governments being this onerous or kind
of abrac it to this technology or are
they actually doing the opposite my
expectation without knowing too much
about kind of these other geographies
and specifically around AI is they're
probably actually like leaning into it
and trying to promote it and say like
hey there's a Global race going
on let's be the winner yeah yeah
definitely China is promoting it but
obviously they have they have uh
malicious uh malet so uh like other
countries are viewing this as like oh
this is interesting like let's say
European countries the our strongest
allies this is interesting but we don't
really understand it and we have other
issues to deal with which is like you
know our society could implode any
moment so you know it's not like Europe
is a big harmonious like country right
now or continent right now right so I
think that's more where it's just
interesting um there the the regulations
around like Hardware is where a lot of
these countries are focusing which I
actually think is legitimate that like
China has a track record of putting crap
into things we buy to spy on us and to
take IP like they have a history of that
that's fine the EU is really leaning on
the US to lead that way because
obviously we control Swift so in
treasuries and so that is like the
biggest uh force and by the way like
those rules are also applying to allies
like Saudi Arabia so like you know
they're they're it's a I think there's
like 20ish countries it's actually
applying to uh not just China but
obviously China is like the main target
and you know includes other countries
like Iran right which is you know uh
that's good so uh
the the downside I think though is that
China I think is taking it much more
seriously about like how this actually
could be applicable and and much more
functional in terms of its Society
society that I think the US in it's like
you could take it's like one step
forward two step two steps back like
their posture towards Hardware is
correct they their their actual
understanding of AI and how it has
implications to the Brer Society is
wrong like they they you know the belief
around like we need unions now and like
any like you know uh going back to Allin
right you know calcon AIS saying we need
like a writers Union for like content
like and it's just I don't even know
what to deal with that like it's it's
it's so five years away that they and
also like an overe extrapolation of
actually what these LMS can do they're
great and they're GNA be quite useful um
but we're we're getting way ahead of
ourselves to the I prefer like trying to
correct correct something on the backend
side than trying to predict it and the
US is being a much more predictive mode
uh on like how it's going to be bad and
how it's be good and you you're a sort
of land of like neutral uh and then
China is like no this is going to be
good for our society um and and so I
think Americans need to understand that
like LMS are are great and they're
they're they're going to be uh
revolutionary mini categories typically
categories that require search and
Discovery um but we don't need to uh
most of the Innovation around llms are
basically the ux experience so uh and
and how actually data and content gets
like created and how you actually do
that then there's like that's kind of
the main Innovation the secondary
Innovation are things related to
creative power so Graphics photos images
things that would previously require a
designer all that stuff is also quite uh
impressive um but it doesn't mean that
like that's going to replace artists
like you know a Picasso is still a
Picasso right so like it's a people are
getting way ahead of themselves in terms
of thinking that this is actually going
to accurately replicate the creative
power of humanity it can accurately uh
I'd say replicate you hiring someone
from Fiverr to write you a blog post it
can do that right but telling me that's
going to be Hemingway right is is come
on like be serious right now right the
they there there is a great thing and
like it's basically I always VI
Innovation you know I'm not part of the
uh was it the E Dash ACC whatever I'm
not really there but I'm kind of
somewhere between uh because I think I
think technology has morality to be
Associated but we don't need to stop so
I always view like Innovation steps as
replacing something that was already low
valued in the system and allows humans
to be more CA so it it's like we live in
a Star Wars world not a Star Trek world
so AI is enabling other sentient
creatures and creatures that have
morality and free will to do more human
things to be greater artists to be
greater you know things that are
uniquely human right uh creativity power
right etc etc so AI is going to be more
useful to to people to be more creative
and to do greater things versus the Star
Trek orientation which I think is where
the bid Administration is and where like
a lot of people who or AI researchers
but then you talk to them actually about
how they understand intelligence and
they really literally think that humans
are just a computer and like okay this
is just a reflection of your priors not
actually true based on the autological
framework that we exist in the world so
Star Trek I do not believe has actually
ever been proven I like if you look at
the history of innovation malthusian uh
like MOS was wrong like it it just never
happened so the idea that that AI can
come along and replace things and become
his own sentience to where it creates
value right um there's so many things
locked up into that like presuppositions
around like what that means uh to to
give people kind of a step back to maybe
calm their nerves remember self-driving
that all oh self-driving replace truck
drivers which is one of the highest paid
careers right now we're play Oh taxi
cabs oh this right none that happened
right
because I know and I was actually on
record saying in back in 2014 or
something like that saying that that's
not going to happen right because there
are so many assumptions people had about
like how roads work and why we designed
it around humans that like humans
innately through intuition which you
don't understand exactly about like how
intuition Works um that like you can't
map into a zeros and one like you you
you like you can look at down you know
down Market Street you can look at that
and understand what to do right just
just by intuition but how you tell via
intuition to a
computer humans designed into something
like that like there's all these
assumptions built into that road that
aren't even articulated like you can't
articulate it's just through years and
years of research and and iteration
that's designed around humans and to say
like a robot is just going to come in
and SC stuff and like come to that
intuition is just absurd like it's like
that's not how it's it's works it's not
zeros and ones that create intelligence
and knowledge humans create design
intelligence it requires agency right uh
and and this is all basic you know um
philosophical points that you would know
if you said theology or Socrates or the
classics but a lot of people in Tech
don't know anything about those they
don't know anything about like they
never read John Lock's theory about Free
Will right and so they they come with
like really cool things like computing
power llms right machine learning and
really great Innovations and then they
say it's going to replace all this stuff
and I'm always like no it's never
happened like they there's it's always
created more things more opportunities
more wealth for people and in any of the
stories of replacement if you go back
look historically you're like it's
exaggerated that's not really what
happened like if anything it's like a
local it's like a within one
generationally CA let's say like
automobile to to horses right or or
sorry other way around horses
automobiles if you actually look at the
the job created right um it it it was
more of a plateau and then decline but
the adoption of the automobile took
decades right to actually get to that
point point and and the same thing will
be with llms same thing with
self-driving is that it it at first will
enable humans to be more human so you
know work on highways it'll work like on
like low sort of variability
environments and then it'll go
Downstream right but it has to solve the
simplest use case first and so llm is
the same thing like if it can't you know
hallucinate and if it constantly
hallucinates which we can't really
control either yet we can try but it
takes time uh like if it can't repeat
back a book accurately you can't tell me
that people are gonna like it's going to
replace doct trators right because if an
LM goes south who you going to blame
like like the the the the morality the
agency on the other side of like if
something goes wrong right is a key part
of our society and it's a basis of our
justice system so to say that you know a
self-driving cars drive on the street
and hit somebody and like we don't know
who's responsible society's not going to
tolerate that like so that's like a a
whole other level of like anthropology
that like people and Technology don't
understand is like Society has to have a
functional just
framework um to to work through these
Innovations which is why like yes it's
bleeding edge Cutting Edge it's super
cool we can see the future but as
andreon says like you know constantly
people uh overestimate in the short term
and underestimate the long term 100%
agree that like that in the long term
llms
gpus AI are going to transform lots of
parts of our society but it's not going
to happen within like you know five
years we're talking about two decades a
decade or something like that
when we think about AI I look at it idea
software Hardware right it's kind of
like there's this overarching uh idea it
feels like today that is where
politicians and Regulators are focusing
all their time and effort they're like
oh these are scary ideas to your point
kind of Star Trek versus Star Wars you
know type thing um the software it seems
like there is a battle between open
source versus closed source and
different companies and different you
know kind of thought processes you are
more so going after the hard Ware
component and you're saying hey these
gpus are going to be pretty damn
important and there are different
strategies here can you outline your
strategy versus like the other
strategies when it comes to the the
hardware itself yeah yeah so so we we
think that you know that this will
follow a very similar Trend to to cell
phones and what happen with the chip
makers there uh which is like you have
an initial burst uh like for a couple
years were very very or uh lots of value
creation on chipmaker side
uh because people want the chips they
find a use case and there's a shortage
and then it goes into the next phase
which is infrastructure development so
like Cloud hosting uh platform companies
and then the last phase actually is
consumers right so consumer goods and so
so that is if you look at that that's
took of a course of 12
Years different things were created
during that time frame right and and so
we think same going happen with gpus
like I think gpus is basically what
Quantum oh Quantum Quantum right GP gpus
is actually the thing that's going to
going to work right and it has downsides
which is like gpus are terrible at any
sort of complex workload right they're
very very good at parallelization so
which are very simple jobs so if if
there's a transition point which we'll
see with these great Toppers that are
coming out which could be absolutely
incredible um that the combination of
both high performance CPU and high
performance GPU to be able to com
combine those could be actually the
thing that actually transforms a lot of
workloads uh because there are still CPU
like most of the workloads in you know
plow can actually be done by gpus um and
like you know video rendering and and
which are heavy heavy on on CPU side uh
like those are all things that occupy a
lot of horsepower there right so I only
see that gpus are basically uh because
they they are so dense uh they are
immensely powerful for what in terms of
teraflops uh for their for their size uh
and that Apple obviously release the GPU
into their phone that's where uh we're
going to see sort of this next phase of
movement which is a combination I don't
really believe in replacement I think
over the course of time things kind of
like co-mingle all go into hybrid mode
and then it then splits where you have
people who continue on hybrid mode
continue old old mode and continue on on
new mode so I always like to use cars or
watches as examples for these things so
as an examp as great for everyone knows
hybrids like obviously PRS was the thing
that like transformed the market right
and and so we still have the
continuation of normal cars and we have
hybrid and have Absolute Electric right
and so that's going to be for a long
time going to be the orientational
hardware CPU is still going to be the
dominant form of computing
infrastructure but we're going to have
like hybrid and an absolute you know
sort of GPU and both of those th those
um new markets are going to be most of
the growth in infrastructure over the
coming 10 years but it doesn't mean that
the 300 or 400 billion do CPU Market is
not huge and it's growing slowly right
but the GP Market is just going to like
you know ramp up and continue to do that
because it generally always creates as
you have new inventions it creates more
wealth and more and and greater growth
uh so our our belief is that from our
company is that more gpus out in the
market the better it's going to be
especially as you go into reer cleaning
pool uh uh refurbishing side which
you've only started seeing the beginning
of that gpus become cheaper and cheaper
and you know their lifespan can be five
to seven years uh and that that's going
to be pushed more CPU usage into uh gpus
and we're going to be more in a hybrid
mode for the coming four or five years
as people continue to experiment gpus
find is very useful for certain things
very very useful for certain things and
then not for others and continue to
invest in CPU and GPU uh so we we are
building a platform to we make it it
doesn't matter if you want to get uh a
card in Texas or a card in Sweden uh the
same interface same API same security
Keys uh all the Frameworks are the same
you can access any data center of the
world so that's our goal is to be the
kayak or the Airbnb for gpus where you
can get any GPU at any day Center in the
world so we currently manage about a
hundred million dollar worth of GPU
infrastructure right now uh you go on
our website you can buy everything from
an A10 up to an h100 uh and we're
completely agnostic to any form of
Hardware we actually even have
alternatives to the Nidia of they do
exist uh and they're putting that on
their platform from Intel from AMD um
the more gpus the better because people
are going to be in experimentation phase
for the next five years as they go
hybrid right as they try these different
you know ways of incorporating gpus into
into their stack uh but but we are
seeing very clear adoption very fast and
very clear adoption among Enterprises uh
but you know we're not going to go you
know bait and switch and cancel all of
our CPUs like the CPUs are still very
very useful but I think it's going to be
more and more like the uh what the race
Hopper is leaning into or the new uh
h100 that's going to come out uh end of
next year we boosting CPU usage within
the GPU framework in this hyper approach
is going to be what people ask for as I
try to figure out what to do with this
new
technology now what's interesting to me
is let's take geography as um kind of
one you know uh lens of this for one
aspect so I have seen some people say
hey we're going to build centralized
data centers and we've got this amazing
stuff um I know of a company uh Northern
data in Europe that seems to have one of
the bigger clusters there and that seems
to be a competive Advantage for them
there are companies here in the United
States that say hey we have certain
capabilities or geog Geographic
advantages uh as well I then even saw I
think it's called Dell complex they want
to build like the compute you know
Center and The Sovereign Nation floating
in the sea uh and they've got kind of a
whole plan and and uh whether that's
possible or not like they're going to go
attempt it what you all are basically
saying is like well what if we just
actually create a layer on top of all of
these people and then you can just pick
and choose depending on the day the the
job the specific you know regulatory
thing that you're trying to solve for
and so as you uh have gotten you know
started with this two questions
immediately pop to mind how many people
know where they want to be they're like
specifically I want you know GPU from
Texas or from this European country
versus they just want diversification in
general and they just you know they want
to try to avoid
centralization so yeah so I I I think
that what's going to be very interesting
with uh What gpus uh will change as a
secondary effect uh that hasn't been I
guess fully appreciated in the market is
that because they are so energy dense AK
expensive to run uh and they're also
small that it's going to re reimagine
how you think of data centers and terms
of the World Market so the uh I do think
you're going to see smaller data centers
in more interesting places with attached
to renewable energy or attached to some
form of like cheap energy source uh that
that's going to be the break of the
market because the the the cost of
running a GPU compared to CPU you're
looking at you know maybe 10 times
magnitude uh and and that matters More
For Real Estate purposes right real like
the actual physical uh components of a
data center matter much more than ever
before versus CPU you know you're
talking about single digigit points and
stuff like that on running a bunch of
CPUs so you can't just run it in
Virginia as well as like gpus are not as
sensitive based on how people use it on
networking between different countries
right so versus gpus that's much more
important so this is why like I think
it's becomes more hybrid is that like
there gpus are just really good right
now at very specific things that they
can only be very good at and so we're
gonna have this fracturing now of like
Mega data centers that are still going
to exist because CPUs need to be in a
mega day Center and the cost of running
it is just you know kind of unbeatable
but for these like next wave of
computing it's going to be much more
modular it's going to smaller or be like
Beyond ships or something like that to
where they find an advantageous place on
the real estate side and also the eny
side uh so that's like that forcing
function and that's actually not
changing because the if you look at the
arc as Tera flops increase per new GP
card the energy cost to run those is
actually linear so so they have not been
able to break that curve so as you know
for for example Grace Hoppers you know
like it for most data centers it would
literally running one Grace Hopper would
explode the data right like so so like
that even that like the energy is
increasing right so you know like there
was one uh estimate I think from Ireland
or is Iceland like 25 30% of their
injury costs like are actually just data
centers right so that's only going to
get worse uh as people go shift towards
Advanced Computing um and and so when
customers are coming to us mostly
looking at just I need to find a card to
do something specific so that's why
that's also the first thing looking
around the distributed compute is that
because there's less in like actual like
ISP need so like getting data to the
data center as it relates to gpus
they're much more interested in being
distributed because there's not enough
cards and so they're much much more
concerned around pricing ative cards
that's pushing it to be distributed um
the second is that the uh a lot of these
companies are going into Sovereign llm
hosting because the price of the GPU is
so expensive that you're like well I can
just buy my own hardware and it can pay
back itself in a year right so so the
and then you have the other side which
is like the shortage which is like you
know if you're running for example the
train session and someone kicks you off
like the train session is done it's like
there's no like pausing it and then
restarting it right it's like all that
work that was done is just L right so so
there there is a a strong desire to
shift towards their own infrastructure
because of you know the shortages and uh
and the fact that the hardware itself is
immensely valuable and they just want to
run their own Hardware because they just
want to run a model anytime they want um
so so that it is having a renewed impact
uh on the Colo space and and sort of
REITs that are part of data centers
because there this huge movement now
back to Bare Metal uh and you have like
the obviously King of the Hill is NVIDIA
which are is running this prison yard
game of like trying to get cards and
stuff like that trying to control the
supply but they don't really want to
sell to public Cloud uh they don't want
to be in the same position going back to
that that same uh metaphor about the
phone market you know Intel and Etc like
IBM were amazing growth right and then
crash and crater right as the next wave
of infrastructure companies took over
and owned that customer segment right so
Nvidia knows that and and Jensen is very
smart and so obviously he he went from
gaming to Ai and like and and machine
learning and that was an amazing play by
him so he knows that like the next wave
is actually disintermediating the value
of the Chip And and you know I think
every major Cod company maybe said
Microsoft uh is working on their own GPU
card right because they want to be held
to Nvidia Nvidia knows that so Nvidia is
trying to push as close to the customer
as possible so they're trying to get
footprint they're trying to get to Data
Centers so that they can have an actual
place and a physical location so they
cannot be disintermediated like you can
with public Cloud uh and so yeah sure
public cloud is still one of the largest
buyers but if you talk to anyone like
Works in Nidia like you know they're
like we don't we they they do uh they do
not want that to be continued
relationship because anyone Nvidia wants
to have Nvidia customers right they
don't want to have Amazon uh through
Amazon type of customers um which is
which is smart like it is quite smart
and uh their whole dgx is is also trying
to do that their software packages Cuda
like these are all trying to create that
footprint uh and permanence and to uh to
be fair to them it is still the best
like there is nothing that really comes
close to anything that they produce
versus what's on the AMD or or IBM side
uh if you have a very specific specific
like say pie torch you know package or
workload yeah you can probably get an
IBM uh GPU that can do something very
similar but the the power of the
generalized uh framework that which uh
nid has created is right now unbeatable
uh and and so you know they I think
they're going to be Kings for at least
another two three years what is your
greatest fear when it comes to these
kind of like Advanced Computing Wars
there's nation states there's company
competition there is regulation like
what's the uh do day scenario in your
mind that we have to work diligently to
avoid this episode is brought to you by
aradine they are a brand new startup led
by a number of Silicon Valley Legends
who just raised $81 million to build the
future of Internet infrastructure you're
probably wondering what that means let
me explain there are numerous new
disruptive technologies that are being
adopted simultaneously from blockchain
to artificial intelligence to zero
knowledge Technologies in order to
ensure that these Technologies thrive in
this new world we need new
infrastructure and that is where arine
comes in they just launched their first
product line called Tera flux which is a
Bitcoin miner powered by the world's
first 4 nanometer silicon chip
technology these air cooled singlephase
and dual-phase emerging cooling miners
have unrivaled speed and efficiency
they've Superior uptime and they
leverage a brand new innovation called
Energy tune that allows miners to
dynamically adjust the energy
consumption and Bitcoin hash rate based
on demand response needs of the
electrical grids aradine is an ambitious
company working on hard problems I'm
really impressed with them and if you
want to check out more you can go to
idine.com that's Au a d ne.com go check
them out at radon.com
today uh I would probably only say the
the negative case where we
become so obsessed about the possible
negative downsides that we lose the
ability to actually continue to lead
here and that would be I think the the
the thing that would be the biggest fear
is that we we become obsessed with what
you know we saw in uh Black Mirror and
that becomes like orientation of what
this technology is versus the reality
the historical truth the just nature of
humanity is that it ends up being like a
net gain and yeah there's downsides but
those downsides generally are like
already human pathologies right like
it's like if you cut off you know if you
go back and do prohibition again right
humans will still find other pathologies
right because our nature is to find
pathologies is to find addictions to
find medications to our own internalized
drama our own internalized story so I I
think that that is the the the the
biggest concern is that politicians
specifically who are immensely
uninformed I mean you just look at them
physically they they they look
uninformed even though they say things
that are uninformed like that we become
more obsessed with the geriatric
Narrative of something they read when
they were in high school back in the
1950s versus like what the future
actually is and where we can go as
humanity and America can still be the
leader so my biggest fear is if America
continues to not want to be a winner to
not want to win and be number one
because Americans don't
appreciate that we are a b a benevolent
Imperial power and we are probably the
first like tell me any other country in
the history of the world uh of human
humankind too just like you know forever
9,000 years of recorded history that
where we invade a country we destroy it
utterly eviscerate it and then we make
it democracy and then we let them go and
we've done that like six times right
Philippines Japan Korea Germany Taiwan
right like we we do this as as a
lifestyle right and and and and I think
we we we we just kind of like almost are
embarrassed by it or we don't appreciate
it but it's beautiful it's it's an
amazing thing that America can be the
absolute power and can still give people
freedom and and that we set the terms
right on what it what it means to be
free within context like and uh with you
know like we still have obviously German
still Germany we're still America but
like we did that right and we should be
very proud of that uh but instead we
sort of have this well we don't want to
be number one and like we gotta let you
know multiculturalism to like you know
we're we're we're a colonizer like I
don't I don't understand it's like do
you believe that you live in this
country and you know most likely your
parents immigrated or their parents or
their parents like how do you not see
that this is the best way to live life
if you don't want as a country you don't
want to have that that is your decision
right but to say that our our style and
our lifestyle is bad or not should not
be promoted is crazy because if China's
promoting theirs and every other country
is promoting theirs but we sort of feel
like no we do we shouldn't right the
more people that follow you know Western
Civ right and and we generally are
though we have you know a very strong
contingent of Americans that do not
believe in Western C but you know the
brella Western Sith it objectively works
like it's a like look at Israel okay so
so the biggest thing of the day right so
before Israel existed right uh before
the whatever 1919 agreement before 1948
47 that whole area was was was like a
shanty town right it was crap right
nobody want to live there it was poor
right didn't have running water
electricity like you know it was it was
like bedwin life right and then they
come along start off actually as a
socialist you know you know with with
the um what's it called the the kabo you
know the the Socialist uh Frameworks
there then they actually became more
free it's one of the few countries in
America in America sorry in world
history that goes from Socialist
Communist orientation to become more
free and it's a paradise now right it is
it is it is a first world country that
has Arabs Jews Christians you know uh
alternative lifestyle live freely have
rights and can vote
and and can make you know significant uh
amount of money compared to anywhere
else in the in the Arab region and
that's because they believed in those
ideas and they followed through with
them right and so that's my orientation
in terms of why I'm in technology why
I'm involved in politics is I want every
human being to have access to that if
they don't choose if they don't want it
whatever if you want if the Gaza and
West Bank want to reject those ideas and
live the way they do that is their
decision but you can't launch rockets
you can't launch terrorist attacks you
can't like destroy
life itself and creativity itself if you
want to be a toxic country you can just
go do that on your own time right and I
think that's the posture that Americans
need to have is uh is that it's it's so
let think this way it's like we're
almost shy way of saying America's a
policeman or our world's
policeman and I I I I kind of like that
word because police are not there all
the time right but we should clearly run
all of the you know the trading routes
we should run treasury we should run
Swift we should we we should run these
things because we actually are a good
benevolent dictator right because who
else is going to run it you can't just
exist in this void of un World
Government nonsense the only reason why
the UN exists is because America says it
exists and we say it's important that's
it no other reason no other explanation
we say it's important therefore it's
important we say Israel is important
therefore Israel is important that is
good we that is a good action and a good
act of our country and a good act of
values and and so when it comes to these
future Technologies we need have the
same approach which just like these are
good things and we believe in the future
Prosperity this can create if you don't
want to do that if you want to be China
if you want to use AI against your
citizens whatever that's your decision
but you're not going to spread to Korea
you're not spread that to Japan you're
not put this in Singapore Philippines
wherever or in Africa like they don't
want your crap they don't like your
bribes they don't like your your failed
infrastructure projects or your airports
that don't work like they don't want
that don't pressure them do that right
that that's how we can be a World's
placement it doesn't mean we launch
missiles into freaking Shanghai right
but it me clearly means that this is how
the world works you can participate or
you don't if you don't you can you know
hurt your own people but don't hurt the
rest of the
world give me the ultra bll case AI eak
uh you know technologist take over the
world the Utopia gets built um ju just
like everything works what does that
world look like uh I think there' be a
lot more people uh I'm on the Elon train
more people love people I don't know how
you fly over America and be like there's
to many people like it's like people are
people are great uh and uh more more
people uh technology creates human
flourishing and to use a tri FL on the
center right um I think it would be that
um there would probably actually be more
onshoring uh I do think the llms uh kind
of reimagine the way we think about like
low wage work um I I think that it would
it enables other sort of more technical
jobs that that would
be uh you know on the lower end side
that could like move people up so rather
than working at fast food they're
working at a data center that's like
working on you know technical L LM
machines still working with their hands
uh I actually think that the the best
case is more movement of manufacturing
back to America uh because we're re
we're understanding the importance of
infrastructure and the importance of
doing things ourselves and one of the
downsides there it's so interesting like
Souls you know soul is very famous for
right writing about secondary effects
right that's like his big emmo right he
does about race he does about welfare
right uh voting rights everything right
his books are always great about that
the secondary effects right of China
lying about Co has been that like people
are like wow it's actually not the
cheapest place to produce stuff anymore
in China it's actually Mexico all right
almost almost all the goods all it's
better to do Mexico oh they're actually
like hostile oh they're actually like
spying on us oh they're actually taking
it actually opened up all of this stuff
right where like before we're like you
know libertarian neoliberal oh just
trade and everything will work out right
like as if like you can bribe a bully on
the playground with candy every month
and like that would make him like not
beat you up right so so we we we have it
the secondary effect of like what China
did was that it reopened everybody to
the fact of like we actually should not
rely on one country to boo everything
and it's not the best country at at many
of those things and so the China plus
strategy on supply chain is like a
permanent feature of like every major
multinational now so that's a down like
China loss there um another secondary
effect right is that all the blue cities
that host all these tech companies are
doing terribly right they supported the
lockdowns and they continued it they
continued the mandates vaccine to mask
whatever and it just destroyed their
economy right it destroyed no one want
to live there they just like moved to
Florida or Texas or Arizona or Colorado
where I am and and so like the the
secondary order effects is like where
where I think the the the the the
maximum upside is where we can actually
see like yeah llms great good transform
products I think most llms are gonna be
features so uh like is in when you go to
Charles Schwab they have their own llm
but it's not going to be like an llm
company right I think there's going to
be very limited number of those people
like maybe open AI right uh from a
consumer perspective but the number of
winners are going be very very small
most of the winners are going to be
Integrations into other products uh and
and because the value of that llm is
like the U and the data and and that's
something that a company can do
themselves and probably will do
themselves you Schwab is just going to
give over all of its data to open AI to
run no of course not right like they run
their whole freaking colos like they run
all their own infrastructure think
Goldman Sachs is going to do that or
American Airlines or United no they run
they're all they're all on colon right
so they have their own infrastructure so
they're just going to build their own
own llms so the open source world is
going to win uh it just it's going to
move way too fast all the proprietary
model stuff is going to go I think South
like it there'll be a couple big Winners
just as brand names that you just use
but the the the ability to like not have
ownership over your LM I think it
creates too much uh secondary order risk
uh as in responsibility like you know
imagine there's an llm for Donald Trump
right uh which would be freaking
hilarious but like let's say it says
something that it doesn't believe right
like a trump doesn't actually believe
but that's run by a third party so but
who is gonna be held accountable to the
public eye it' be actually the whoever's
running the Trump La at the at the
organization not the third party so that
like you know those scenarios where it
would hallucinate or fail if they don't
own that infrastructure that data they
don't they can't just throw it to a
third party they're going to want to own
it themselves right so they can want
change the waiting they can change the
the areas that are like these sort of
like I would say edge cases but like
hallucinations um and they can have
actually ownership over that so they can
like say like you know you did that
wrong go fix it right versus throwing to
a third party so I think that that the
most of the LMS that are going to see
that are going to dominate the market
are going to exist in that zone where
has to have like 95% up accuracy and I
just can't see if you look at other
things Enterprises have done where it is
that for like up time right say for
hosting they generally build their own
stuff right they they they they don't
want to Outsource that to a third party
that they can't control uh and so that's
where I think llm is mostly gonna be
feature so then the secondary effects of
that are going to be jobs like just just
different ways of working with llms
different types of people who manage
llms uh the infrastructure behind it uh
new ways of like doing uh customer
service uh is g to open up another like
so I I see most positive impacts uh on
jobs and wage growth uh do not see much
negative impacts uh and again the more
people that we can move up the chain to
where they can you know we can create a
good lifestyle for people who you know
don't go to college and who have uh want
to work with their hands uh I I think
that's where we have seen a lot of the
failed American dream is that we as I
know like you know you've talked about
it's like telling people to go through a
system of indoctrination to get a degree
has obviously not worked so we need to
provide other means and silon Valley can
actually provide those me uh if we allow
it to flourish and go forward I I I have
no idea why people think as the as the
Biden EO about AI is going to replace
manufacturing jobs I have it's literally
bizarre like it's it's just I don't even
understand it's if they're going to make
a machine to have l in it to do
something need a person to push the
thing to make the thing to get it and to
move it right it's manufacturing it's a
physical good right so it's going to
have more capability for more people to
go do that job because it' be easier for
them to do right but it's it's just a uh
a total like politics is and it's on
both sides not just this is Biden is
current president so I mean I think if
there was a republican especially
mainstream establish Republican it would
have been a very similar EO um they just
don't understand like how wealth gets
created how value gets created at a
company and the innate importance of
humans in that value creation process
instead and if you look at how they
actually legislate they don't really
care about people they don't really
understand them they live in this like
aloof world where they think that
everyone cares about zalinsky and the
Freedom Movement in Ukraine nobody does
right nobody right and and oh give I
can't wait till I can't wait till we see
the grifts and the graph that like has
been done on the Ukraine war and the
people like oh my God how did that
happen look literally what we did he's a
freaking corupt person that has banned
freedom in this country it's like a
Putin versus Putin right so what he
didn't invade Poland or freaking Finland
he invaded another autocracy so of
course there's gonna be massive grips
like all of a sudden these weapons end
up in Iran I wonder how that happen
right uh it's it politicians just as it
comes to AI is a Rel other things they
just live in this alternative reality
where they they they do not have
attachment to people and that that's the
whole like other side conversation but
like yeah I think the whole legislative
branch and all stuff needs to be
reformed to where it actually represents
things that people want and they feel
like they have actual voice in the
system not this because the current
situation you have is like massively
unstable is it's a it's it's scary but I
mean we'll work it out America has
worked it out several times before but
it it the the the level of ins
Insurgency of anti-west ideas in our
country is is immensely concerning uh
and we just sort of continue to play
games with Ukraine war oh like send
missiles over there like ver the stuff
in front of us now we just ort of push
on the rug and be like no it's just yeah
we just ignore it they're just you know
kids who playing along with like a
narrative like no this is like
ideological self-destructive behavior
that if you read you know uh IND
biography about Russia it became
massively uncontrolled and Russia became
communist because 7,000 it was just
7,000 people that part of the buic party
took over an interm government that was
chaotic and then they became communist
like it doesn't take many people to
destroy something and and we just sort
of you know oh who cares right it's just
kids playing right no this is like a
very serious thing in our
country has America gone too far can it
be saved can we roll it back build a
better go build a better future yeah I
love I mean if Trump can become
president dude like you know yes like
the country still has lots of energy in
it uh and besides like what else do we
have right in silon Valley there was you
know it used to be a joke right that
like oh if America goes south well they
go to North or New Zealand right well
look what happened there so like New
Zealand was was freaking hermit Kingdom
for three years right do you really want
to move there those freaking people are
crazy right so uh there there's no
there's nothing left there there's no
parachute there's no exit option like
the best would be Israel right but
Israel was bad on Co but the best now
would say be Israel um and because
they're they're gonna fight to win like
they they they they they will the desire
to be alive into to have humans that
live in a successful safe Society in
Israel is a shared belief regardless
whatever party you vote for and and it's
immensely beautiful and admirable uh and
and you remember like that that movie
World War Z with like Brad Pit and they
you know they become a zombie in like 10
seconds right so in that movie there's
like two countries that survive
America's freaking toast right so of
course it would be right except like
Texas I think in the movie it just make
sense so um and so the other one the two
ones that remain are North Korea and and
Israel right and North Korea because
they pull out everyone's teeth and they
shut down all the borders right and and
so they surviv but no one has teeth and
Israel right they survived because they
build a massive wall to predict all
their cities right and and they what are
they doing in the movie they're letting
people in that was so true about Israel
like that like and I've been there and I
know many uh Israeli politicians I know
like former ambassadors of Israel I love
Israel um they're letting in all types
of people like Palestinians Muslims
right in the movie and and and Israel is
protecting them right because as they
said in the movie like every additional
one of us is less of them that is was
just such a great image of Israel right
uh and I I wish that Americans would see
that like that is who we used to be that
like we used to love immigration
generally we had moments where we didn't
and those frankly those were kind of
Justified like we were letting in way
too many people like during you know the
sort of Five Points New York City gang
rise and things like that they weren't
we were not assimilating properly back
then it' be funny if if if you take
someone from you know uh a New York gang
in like the 19 whatever late 1880s or
1910s and you bring them to racial
politics today they'll be like what do
you mean like I'm Irish like he's German
we're not the same thing and then today
are like no you're all white and they're
like what do you mean like that doesn't
make sense to me right so it's just
funny how historically how things evolve
in terms of narrative you look
culturally speaking doesn't like you go
to Europe now you say like oh you know
Germans and Italians are are all white
they' be like I don't what do you mean
like we're completely different people
right so uh blood and soil matters more
than them than us here I but like the
orientation of like how Israel views
life is what we used to believe and and
that if you believed in our values H and
you and you wanted to come here to
participate in the the the the largest
most successful Multicultural nation in
the history of human civilization then
you should do it uh nobody's complaining
about Nigerians coming here right like
it's because they're immensely
successful like and and and that's what
we want we want people like that who
want to participate in experiment um and
it's a beautiful experiment it's it's
Redemptive having a nation where race is
secondary right to what you bring to the
table which has always been the goal of
our society even from the beginning like
the 1619 project is a lie it's not true
historically not true true no historian
ever just believes it even liberal
historians who hate America say it's
fictitious none of it's true right um
it's a fanciful story about about the
past the orientation of our country has
always been that that's the goal right
is that you what you bring character
values hard work uh your faith your
innate value as a human is how we build
our society not based on land not based
on race not based on you know your
religion or whatever sort of um you know
uh uh Creed that has caused Wars in
other countries that you can come here
and you can be and you can be
free and and that's what we should
continue to press into uh the the
election I think of trump was was less
so a statement I think about him
particularly and more of a statement
that Americans still believe that
America can be great that's actually
what it was it was not him it was not
his family or his character or his he
was he is funny but like his being funny
it was that he said over and over again
that America should be great should be
powerful and should win and that what
Americans should continue to be I and
that's still there it is still there and
someone is GNA leverage that in this
upcoming election uh and I think that's
also what motivates our tech industry is
that that that inre and horrorwitz
Founders fond Lux Capital right like the
the there's still this orientation in
silon Valley for I I would say great
like Elon El's I think my favorite
entrepreneur like that America is the
Hope is the Hope for the world that that
the world can be different and history
can be different it doesn't mean we're
perfect obviously we have lots of
examples of our country of not being
perfect but we are the country that gets
past that reconciles and moves forward
right we are not the country that that
like like basically gazes at our sins
and and self- implodes like every other
country in the history of the world
where we bring up things of the past
constantly and not try to move forward
in the posture of forgiveness and Grace
uh and and so that is the forgiveness
and Grace part is probably where I'm
most concerned about is America lost but
I I still think we're very much on the
side of winning and being number
one when I think of the future I think
about technologists solving problems I
think of young people becoming ambitious
and going for it trying to accomplish as
much as possible I think about Americans
being proud of building things here in
America solving problems here in America
creating a better life here in America
how do we accomplish that from the
earliest stages of someone's life right
you know it's it some countries are very
good at driving patriotism and
nationalism and and these things yeah
other countries were good at it and
getting worse and some just have never
been good at it and so how do you think
about what is the right degree of you
know in America when I went to school we
stood and said the Pledge of Allegiance
I actually don't know if kids do that
anymore or Not Right But like oh yeah I
don't know if they do either like what
what does that look like in terms of we
want to build a stronger country and so
what should we be doing with young
people probably civil service is a
requirement um I think that's a good
solution uh Western sa as a requirement
course uh I think the whole uh Grant
system for higher ed needs to go away uh
I think higher ed needs to live under
its own Laurels and no longer operate on
subsidies based on the federal
government um I think that we should
return back
to um uh some form of uh like how we
view immigration as a combination of
like family and Merit base uh some
combination of both because I I see
merits for to be frank I see for both I
see it's very reasonable to if you get
in to bring your F I think that that's
very reasonable uh and I also think it
should be based on Merit um but it as
well so some blend of that um and but
but a lot of it is just is history it's
like
appreciating where you are in this in
the strand of American life and the most
uh you know like to to use a Biblical
phrase like the the people that uh you
know plants that die in the Sun or get
washed away in the river and are deeply
rooted like so the first is from James
and Matthew the second one's from
Proverbs are people who don't understand
they come from and don't understand what
the past is and if you read the past if
you read deeply into like my favorite
founding father is TJ call TJ because I
love I love Thomas Jefferson um you you
read him and you see a man that is not
only brilliant just like ah he's so
brilliant but a man that struggles with
the question of like obviously slavery
like he both called slavery and he owns
slaves he he called slavery the original
sin of America he also had slaves he
also the first bill he ever endorsed in
the house of Virg in the Virginia when
he was a delegate was the abolition or
the Bas of the possibility of of slave
to be free which was banned in Virginia
right he also included in the
Constitution the Banning of slave trade
in the last paragraph so he's a complex
person right and I think that's where
history has gone from objective analysis
of like people just are complex and they
suck right most of the time and they do
great things still right and and and we
have to see and be empathetic so like
people were really different when the
country was founded as it were different
in the 1950s the 197s and even 20 years
ago and we had to understand the
cultural context that they were in but
not that the relativist like how that's
relative is the actual truth right it's
only meant to design to create empathy
and I think that our educational system
has become completely obsessed with the
relativistic uh narratives within each
in each like Epoch of of our country and
became that became the truth no like
like objective actions that happen and
motivations are like important uh but
you have to like it's a more of a
posture of understanding than it is to
judge and as CS Lewis has a phrase
Americans have become increasingly
detached which is also becoming
decreasing patriotic because of
chronological snobbery they they are
more obsessed with their narcissistic
view about their own morality and ethics
of the day uh which why like Ryan long I
encourage everyone to watch him he has
great videos about right making fun of
Americans and our own sort of you know
we like to smell own farts to use a
South Park phrase uh versus historically
like you would be very different right
and and and and that's where we need to
appreciate where we are in that lineage
and that timeline because then we can
come back and say oh yeah this is why
America is great because we have gotten
past bad things not just bad things
happen of course every country has had
bad things right every country like you
know slavery as an example going back to
Thomas Jefferson thing we the only
country that fought a civil war over it
right and and continue to push against
that the fact that that was in our
country and that was embarrassing to us
like to founding fathers is considered
embarrassing um that and that we
survived that we moved on right and
moved forward in life right obviously
there's still lineages of debt from that
but we still move forward that destroyed
other countries right and that that's
where you you focus on the things that
are different not the things are
Universal uh and as as as like Dennis
Breer always says stuff like that too
that like it's it's not that we had
slavery is that we fought to end it
right um and and and so I've seen to go
back to Israel because when I I was on
um I was looking at the Mount of Olives
and I was like around the the Temple
Mount and above the market you see
Israel the IDF is
teaching all the recruits about what
happened to win uh Jerusalem back and
they have maps and stuff they're
pointing out they're pointing in there's
people they're teachers right and
they're all in military uniforms
and and what they're what what Israel is
amazing at is because it's actually a
life or de question you know they have I
think it's seven million people right
live there and surrounded by you know
you know hundreds of millions of of
Arabs and Muslims and that every person
has to be on the same page right like
every person has to be willing to take
up their arms and fight because it's
literally death for us right if it
doesn't if we don't are successful in
this so they're I think very good at at
creating alignment in the country about
like you know we they have their own
mess obviously with Netanyahu and all
the like political crap that's going on
but when they get attacked they're like
no no no no no we have inter family
issues but Nobody messes with our
country right and and and that's where
Americans need to return back to and I
think it's like a lot of it's like
education and teaching people that the
lineage and the beauty of the American
experiment is that it worked and it was
it's in a lot of it was blessings from
the Lord and luck and just right people
right time uh but we've also have a
system of government that has enabled us
to work through things that have killed
and destroyed an entire Society uh and
that's what I focus on I don't focus on
that we had you know all the
embarrassing things we had in our
country we focus on the winds um because
those winds are so rare in our in global
human civilization that they're
underappreciated because we focus on
things that were
mistakes my last question you're raised
from Founders fund and a few other
investors um has this all
now just come down to like there's based
investors and everyone else how do you
think about kind of the The Venture yeah
yeah it's it it's as I was saying in the
first thing it's like it's split where
like it's not even
really uh it's not even around policy
ideas it's like you said it's like based
it's like people who respect other
people for making a stand like um who's
the guy seoa that's become really famous
on Twitter he's a Jew and he's been
tweeting lot about Israel I forgot his
name um been there yeah yeah so like I
mean I'm sure he's a dumb but like and
I'm not a dam but like what he's doing
is right like he's he's being he's
staying what he thinks and he's being
based I'm like good for you right and
and that group of people like is only
growing because the the the based VC
Community the red pill VC Community
right are people that like are not
really oriented around taxes or even
like candidates it's just this belief
that like I should be able to say what I
want and not be called all these names
especially when you logically think
about what I'm saying and it does not
even come to equate to what that that
the guy has been the guy from has been
insulted by and um but like you you you
what makes Sil Valley amazing is the
fact of like that used to be what made
it great was you challenge status quo
right you would say going to Stanford
was a useless waste of time like like
that used to be the things that we would
say and the the regulatory capture I
think of like Web 2.0 which got way too
intermingled with a B
kind of like sucked in all those people
right where they got you know interested
in power right but you see that like the
natural tendency of what I call Web 1.0
PayPal Mafia andreon Horus Peter teal
right um type of type of folks like
that's still there that's sort of like
rebellious the the challenging the being
heterodox right and even someone who was
sucked in to that you know regulatory
capture big government Obama I'm talking
about Zuck is like moved back right like
you see Zuck and like obviously Zuck is
red pilled right he does CrossFit like
he's doing you know martial arts his
statements about Free Speech right like
he obviously saw like okay these people
are like not my my type right originally
they're kind of playing ball like with
the government and then they're like
holy crap okay no no this is actually
not this is not a good idea right and
and I think that Community is going to
continue the Innovation curve right and
the crypto people Bitcoin a lot of llm
people uh defense Tech um like we're
kind of part of the defense Tech world
uh really hard problems uh sort of
entrepreneurs are going to be continued
being the base people who are
challenging and uh status quo to like
create Innovation to Great human
flourishing and wealth uh there's a
large segment of the tech world that are
you what I would say you know Fair
weathers OR tech people who are only
interested in like flipping companies
not creating long-term value for CI for
our society or for the world and are
just it because it's a label and I think
that world is going to kind of like
continue to be around but kind of
disappear because they're not really
creating anything of value they're just
they're just playing different
narratives um but that core contingent
of like hardcore I call Web 1.0 like the
heart of that which is the you know the
Western sort of cowboy California you
know we can build our own wealth and our
own companies and our own you know our
own world that is still going to drive I
think the majority of innovation and
those investors and those entrepreneurs
are just going to continue to like
isolate and around each other because
who wants a board member on your company
that's like you know supporting what you
know you know like U people who are
terrorists like you know and not just
like like openly and like promoting it
right like and so entrepreneurs now are
like kind of returning back to like okay
we need get we need to get Focus this
stuff is crazy it was fun for a little
bit but I see that these people are
actually not on our side and you know
it's not even political it's just like
you know like you said it's like it's uh
it's like based non-base sort of
Frameworks where can wait send people to
find more about Hydra or find you on the
internet wherever you're hiding uh yeah
Twitter uh AGI nnt and then hydr
host.com uh and I write on substack I
write mostly about masculinity and
religion on substack and then medium
about business stuff uh but yeah like on
Twitter uh you'll kind of see me uh
randomly throw up uh you know different
things I find kind of funny on the
internet um and yeah hydro.com uh is our
is our GPU infrastructure company uh and
hopefully you know giving the world
access to as many gpus as possible so
Aaron I learned so much every single
time that we've talked um I appreciate
that you just say what you think which I
think is a uh a core skill that we need
more people to do in the world so thank
you so much for taking the time to do
this uh and we'll definitely do it again
in the future yeah yeah thanks man